die haben es nächste tier unten gitarre
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das ohr des sports
hätte hier kommen wir heute seinen neuen
video weiteren zettel eingeblendet wie
spielen heute wieder ein google spiel
der finnischen auf der website elgar
google rückwärts die url auf der wir uns
hier befinden ist el google.cn ihr fragt
euch jetzt wahrscheinlich was ist das
hier fünf chancen wir eine web verliert
und ermöglicht aus google ein spiel zu
machen und zwar nicht nur ein spiel
sondern werdet viele verschiedene spiele
beispielsweise underwater gravity
terminal pacman und noch ganz wieder
weitere wachen hier ich würde sagen als
ersten klicken etwa mal auf underwater
und dann sehen wir schon wir haben hier
fische und das google-logo hüfte mehr um
mein gott leute das google-logo flutscht
darunter er nicht an die wenige
draufdrücken einfach ihre wellen
erzeugen hier auch drogen dann trasse
fällen glaube ich da wo der farc in
richtiger wellness schöpfer alter
wenn ich gut drauf drücken kann ich
wählen und schon dass die wellen noch
einfluss haben auf das logo oder helfen
so günstig dann weiter noch da wenn ich
jede welle machen rohstoff- ganz weit
nach links und es kann auch riesige
wellen machen sie mich von unten einfach
hoch 404 nach oben drücken damit kann
ich auch die fürbitten beeinflussen oder
ihnen hier vorne war mithin wegdrücken
nach rechts aber viel werbung werde
nicht ihr seht schon jetzt komplette
searching und alles durcheinander
gebracht das sind alles nur kleine
kurzen spieler die man zwischendurch
macht dazu bei und wurden das damals
unterricht spieler genannt also spiele
die man einfach in irgendwelchen edv
basierten unterrichts klappen stunden
gespielt hat an irgendwelchen schul
laptop ich kann jetzt ja aber auch noch
was ein leben das geht jetzt die
beispielsweise von crafter eindruck auf
enter und ihr wegner funktioniert dann
ganz normal wie google nämlich wenn ich
hier auf 40 der drücken ein paar
sekunden später irgendwie auch nicht
wieder ganz normale google also es
funktioniert doch nicht wenn ich hier
drauf druckaufkommen kräftig enter es
geht doch nicht die nächste sache die
wir uns anschauen werden ist gravity das
heißt sie klicken mal einfach drauf und
ihr seht schon
alles
der frauentag
allen alles liegt hier unten auf dem
boden ich kann hier unten einfach mal
drauf klick und jetzt versuchen kontakte
einzugeben aufbaukurs verkehrt herum das
ist super cool druck auf google search
und funktioniert schon wieder nicht wow
aber funktioniert so heftig gut übrigens
merkt ihr vielleicht schon kleine
unterschied in der tonqualität hier
meine aufnahme zu monte weine ich dass
er gerade mit den um und ihr seht schon
da dann ganze wand die räumlichkeiten
aus dem minister tue ich weiß nicht ob
das diesmal einem youtuber gemacht hat
in einem video aber ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal live im video meine kamera
vom stativ ab und zu etwas dieses
mikrofon und ihr seht schon leute ich
habe ich einfach mitmachen komplette
wand voll mit ketten aus dem lukas job
gemacht ich werde hier noch mehr dran
verändern also hier kommt noch eine
tapete hin die seite ausleben eine
schultafel nicht mit kreide
draufschreiben da unten habe ich vom
plexiglas miley den hatten mir marvin
gemacht noch mal danke an dich mal wenn
sie können einfach mal bei der youtube
suche eigentlich ein geschenk bekommt
ein video fast ganz oben den play button
nach vorne wollte ich noch aufhängen die
ecke drin weil ich noch ein bisschen
schöner machen
das bett hier kompakt sondern da kommt
eine schlafcouch hin da vorne den gästen
hier sind aber diese wand also für dich
megageil dinge fand einfach dass ich
andere youtuber ja so schaumstoff an die
wände klatschen das ist aber nicht so
hygienisch und nicht so gesund und
riecht auch so ekelhaft finde ich das
ding habe ich mir gedacht ich fahr
einfach kissen an die wand ich finde die
besser aus die akustik besser und wir
eine komplette tour hier von der firma
wolters eine vernünftigere lassmann like
da dann sicher ob ihr das wollt oder
nicht wir machen weiter hier mit den
sachen und verließ den gebieten bei
google
gravity ganz auf dem boden googlemail
oder wenn ich da drauf die geräte schon
als ganz normal google aber halt anders
herum deshalb wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise klo kacke pilze eingebe
steht da eigentlich fpk kolk ich weiß
nicht ob es jetzt funktioniert wenn ich
auf google searchwiki jawohl ich dachte
nur die suche wer verkehrt herum aber
jetzt einfach alles verkehrt herum guckt
euch das an alter israel nach unten und
setzt sich jetzt noch gegen den link
draufklicken dann ist es aber ganz
normal
jetzt ist es ganz normal alter auf her
ich weiß nicht was passiert wenn ich
auch images clique dann passiert nämlich
gar nicht wenn ich auf newsclick
passiert gar nicht nett dass hier
jetzt ist wiederum komplett normal also
was wir bisher gemacht haben
underwater wars google mail google map
pack terminal
[Musik]
die internet das internet erfunden wurde
michael jackson und pluto also michael
jackson hat sich den planet mit dem
lasso nicht planeten pluto gekauft der
demokrat im weltraum leute ich will das
noch mal ganz kurz ich erschaffen lassen
finde das ganze über alpentöne und geht
auch um mit dem login vor allem 555 und
jetzt haben wir quasi die möglichkeiten
google earth oder einem feeling lucky
ich brauche jetzt einfach mal elf
definiert wurde der search find ich gebe
jetzt einfach mal einen kontrakt da
drücke auf enter und die pershing
vorkontrakte da kommen jetzt einfach mal
wieder es dann wieder bei google habe
mich jetzt einfach mal lucky und jetzt
gebe ich einfach mal google
beispielsweise eindrücke enter mal
schauen ob google sich mindestens selbst
googeln kann und wir kriegen als meldung
wieder einen error error der google maps
api blablabla dann haben wir das jetzt
auch ausprobiert und es funktioniert
ebenfalls nicht wirklich jetzt einfach
mal oben auf heckmann das heißt wir
haben jetzt hier google als pacman logo
mit drin wer darauf klickte passiert
geht los meine damen und herren ich kann
mich jetzt mit den pfeiltasten hier
aller pacman rom bewegen und motive
teile sammeln bzw
damit zwischendurch von tal extra ein
foto oh mein gott alter das wieder
richtig wäre ja meine fretter nein all
diesen alle hinter mir was wollen die
denn glaube jetzt kann ich die essen
oder ja genau dadurch den ersten
gegessen 200 habe ich bekommen
jetzt gehört es aber schon auf ich kann
mir das ding noch mal holen jetzt kann
ich hier den nächsten treffen da haben
wir den gefressen und hier unten jetzt
eben die restlichen sachen holen leute
also hier nochmal ihnen hier das können
wir dass ich jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen zeit wo mein gott halter was
wollt ihr denn alle wie bekommt er denn
wir alle so lange van der walle und man
wo mein gott leute alter das ist doch
nicht wahr haben eine fräse videocenter
so schwer hier
nein das ich war ich hatte doch vier von
den teilen gebraucht man okay ich habe
jetzt mein zweites leben das heißt ich
kann eigentlich die direkt als erst
hinfahren werde hier irgendwann
vielleicht dasselbe geschafft und kommen
zweites level aber ich würde mal sagen
wir machen weiter mit den google spielen
die haben als nächste tier unten gitarre
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das kann mir
gitarrespielen leute ich kann sogar
aufzeichnen schoppmann recording leute
ich spiele jetzt mit der web retten will
ein lied für euch
[Musik]
die bekommen link angebot können einfach
mal guckt hier nicht gelten vergibt
diesen link dort ein und jetzt wäre
ich würde sagen bedankt gemacht hat ist
auf jeden fall ein großer künstler in
der tat das nächste spiel wird wir haben
es das nicht geben deshalb ich denke
einfach mal drauf und ihr seht schon
hier oben oh mein gott ich kann jetzt
nicht wirklich ich kann er wenig spiel
oder das ist nicht wahr
oh mein gott leute ich kann hier oben
snake spielen ich blicke jetzt einfach
mal auf play teilt sich steuere den
glaube ich jetzt auch mit den
pfeiltasten genau hier steht noch mal
eingeblendet und da fühlt die jetzt
funktionieren das übliche drauf und hier
sehen wir schon vergessen
wahrscheinlich bin ich doch mega
schneller ich komme immer auf den
anderen seiten wieder raus bei
kritisieren wenn ich mich selbst freien
fahre dann bin ich quasi am arsch nach
ergibt noch wachen die mich irgendwie
kaputt machen wie beispielsweise diese
böller da oben glaube ich dass jetzt
gerade nicht so super
ich hab verloren leute ich frage mich
gerade die ganze welt fahren frei da
komme ich da recht daraus aber so wird
man natürlich nicht erst da das heißt
ich habe hier weiter meine pilze an und
als möglicher ich finde es einfach so
mega geil das manchmal wie auf der
website google alle diese spiele wow
cool schon wieder gestorben dass man auf
der website google was er eigentlich
eine website ist mit dem sinn ok das ist
verziehen man kann da ist irgendwie
sachen suchen und sich in vom warum spot
direkt vor mir so ein ding ist es
möglich dass sachen zu suchen und so
weiter aber das ist laut diese website
schon wieder ist dass der komplette
ernst das ist einfach mit hilfe dieser
webseite muss das ist doch nicht war die
ganze zeit direkt vor mir mit dieser
website ist es einfach möglich auch
google nicht nur eine vertändeln zu
machen sondern einfach etwas womit man
ja spiele spielen kann einfach sich die
zeit vertreiben kann
die zeit war vorbei und ich hab nur 36
geschafft ich glaube ihr wisst was ich
meine
ich bin sehr begeistert davon die
anderen sachen die wir unten haben den
bingo paper ip location wo man genau
sehen kann wo man im fundbüro aber das
müsse jetzt glaub ich nicht ob man da
keine spieler sind wieder eltern die das
handy auch beenden wenn euch das ganze
gefallen hat und ich das noch mal machen
soll bezwingen was mit anderen google
spielen machen soll dann lasst mal gerne
daumen hoch da wenn ihr jetzt darauf an
seit' an seit' mal google in die
kommentare
daran will ich immer wer von euch nicht
wieder zuende angeschaut hat schreibt
mir auch gerne in die kommentare ob ich
eine komplette motor machen weil er mir
findet hier ein smiley eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf klickte abonniert in meinen
kanalarbeiten verpasst keine videos
merten kostenlos einfach mal machen oder
wirklich freuen uns hier ist mein job
eingeblendet wurde unter anderem die
ganzen kniffe kaufen können und hier
essen anderes video eingeblendet